the marching band is holding a raffle at
a football game with two prizes after
the first ticket is pulled out and the
winner determined the ticket is taped to
the prize the next ticket is pulled out
to determine the winner of the second
prize are the two events independent
explained now before we even think about
this exact case let's think about what
it means for events to be independent it
means that the outcome of one event
doesn't affect the outcome of the other
event now in this situation the first
event the first event after the first
ticket is pulled out in the winner
determined the ticket is taped the
ticket is taped to the prize then the
next ticket is pulled out to determine
the winner of the second prize now the
winner of the second prize the possible
winners the possible outcomes for the
second prize is dependent on who is
pulled out so that for the first prize
you can imagine if if the if there's
three tickets let's say there's tickets
a B and C in the bag and the first and
for the first prize they pull out ticket
a they pull out ticket a that's for the
first prize for the first prize now when
we think about who could be pulled out
for the second prize it's only going to
be tickets B or C it'll only be tickets
B or C now the first prize could have
gone the other way it could have been a
B and C the first prize could have gone
to two ticket B and then the possible
outcomes for the second prize would be a
would be a or C so the possible outcomes
for the second event for the second
prize are completely dependent are
completely dependent on what happened
where what ticket was pulled out from
for the first prize so these are not
independent events the second event the
outcomes for it are dependent on what
happened in the first event so they are
not they are not independent independent
the way that we could have made them
independent is after the first ticket
was pulled out if they just wrote down
the name or something
and then put that ticket back in instead
they tape through the prize but if they
put that ticket back in then the second
prize it would still it would still had
all the tickets there it wouldn't have
mattered who picked out who was picked
out in the first time because their name
was just written down but their ticket
was put back in and then you would have
been independent so if you had to
replace the ticket you would have been
independent but since they didn't
replace the ticket they taped it the
prize these are not independent events